un documentaire signé Yve geland bonsoir
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous à vos
côté Renaud déi bienvenue vous êtes
directeur de la rédaction du Nouvel
Observateur à ma gauche Bernard bled
bienvenue vous êtes ancien secrétaire
général de la Ville de Paris ancien
directeur de cabinet de genantilberry
également et enfin Michel cota vous êtes
journaliste bien sûr éditorialiste au
point notamment et à Europe 1 merci à
tous d'être là alors il jolent pourquoi
Bertrand de la Noé racontez-nous cette
histoire bah d'abord c'est une histoire
qui a commencé il y a longtemps moi
Bertrand lanoué je l'avais je voyais qui
c'était quand j'étais adolescent et que
j'habitais Carcassonne et qu'il était
porte-parole du Parti socialiste et que
voilà on commençait à le voir un petit
peu à la télévision et puis je suis
devenu parisien et puis j'ai réalisé un
documentaire avec de nombreux acteurs
dont l'un est à cette table aujourd'hui
Bernard bled une histoire qui a commencé
en
1999 où Bertrand de laanoué faisait
partie des personnages possible savez
quand on réalise un documentaire il y a
une distribution et avec Pascal sauvage
qui travaillait au journal Le Monde à
l'époque on a décidé qu'on allait
raconter l'histoire de de années qui
précédaient le scrutin de 2001 pensant
que après je sais pas si si vous
souvenez tout ça c'est le siècle dernier
mais il y avait eu déjà une fronde en
98 menée par Jacques Toubon un PCH
avorté et
donc moi j'avais lu ça dans le monde
dans Libération et je me disais dis donc
j'aimerais bien être une petite souris
pour voir comment ça se passe et je me
disais que ça allait être vraiment des
jeux de pouvoir intéressants et donc on
dit mais avec qui et c'est vrai que
Bertrand de laanoué en 99 c'était pas le
personnage central en tout cas peu de
gens penser qu'il allait être candidat
ou peut-être candidat à la candidature
et et on va pendant ces ces 2 ans voir
cette homme passer de candidat à la
candidature mais bien sûr qu'il sera
évidemment battu par Jacques Lang puis
finalement non et puis finalement il est
candidat mais il sera évidment battu par
ce gin et finalement non il est maire de
Paris et
donc ce qui m'intéressait que c'était un
de mes tout premiers films la dernière
fois où où je le filme c'est le soir il
est 2h du matin c'est le soir de son
élection ou 3h du matin raccompagne on
va de chez lui et puis on se quitte quoi
et plus jamais je le filmerai on se
verra de de temps en temps mais toujours
avec une distance et il avait détesté le
film d'ailleurs je sou s'appelait Paris
à tout prix et et puis voilà et dans ma
tête il y avait toujours l'idée dans une
forme radicalement différente de
retrouver cet Hommel que j'avais filmé
pendant 2 ans mais cette fois-ci pendant
2 jours c'estd de matinées en faire un
film d'une he c'est ce que j'allais vous
demander ça vous a pris combien de temps
en fait ces plateaux ça a été 8h
d'entretien donc on a gardé 1 heure sur
les 8h si parfois vous savez je pense
que 1 heure sur 8h pour Paris à tout
prix je me souviens en salle de montage
j' avais gardé 1 % donc 1 heure sur 8h
ça ça reste c'est un montage qui est
toujours plus plus court que que
certains films dans lequel je peux me
lancer où on reste 6 mois sur la table
de montage ouais euh donc oui ça a été
deux matinées et je tiens à à dire
d'ailleurs que c'est on les diffuse
aujourd'hui sur Public Sénat mais
c'était un entretien qui a été fait
alors que Bertand de laanou était maire
de Paris cétait en janvier 2013
exactement et
donc il avait il m'a laissé très libre
mais il avait quand même des des des
choses auquelles il tenait c'estàd la
période à laquelle on allait faire cette
ent oua et ce qui est intéressant c'est
de voir qu'il a déjà une réflexion assez
avancée et et poussée sur l'après mais
on y reviendra il s'était beaucoup
préparé à cet entretien ce qui me
faisait peur au départ et finalement ça
n'a pas empêché une honnêteté une
sincérité vous étiez satisfait de de ce
qui vous a donné je crois qu'il m'a pas
baladé en tout cas parce que là pour le
coup quand on filme pendant 2 ans avec
beaucoup de personnages on a plein de
matière là sil décidait de soit s'il
était pas en forme ou si il était trop
langue de bois s'il partait dans des
tunnels enfin il y en a eu quelquesuns
après il y a eu le travail de montage
derrière he c'est 8h encore une fois
dure 1 heure aujourd'hui bien sûr
c'était le risque c'est-à-dire de de de
de me dire bah peut-être que tout
reposer enfin beaucoup de choses reposé
il y a bien sûr des archives il y a un
petit commentaire mais il y a y a
surtout cet entretien là donc oui à la
fin j'étais je trouvais qu'en tout cas
il avait joué le jeu même si jouit le
jeu est une expression double chambre
qu'est-ce qu'il en a pensé de ce
documentaire là ce serait mentir de dire
qu'il l'a préféré à Paris à tout prix le
film pas aimé donc si si il l'a préféré
il l'a préféré il l'a préféré à Paris à
tout prix pourant il n'avait pas aimé
voilà Paris à tout prix autant ce film
là il y a une chose sur lequelle il il
était très très pas du tout satisfait
c'était le titre voilà la libéré alors
pourquoi vous avez choisi ce titre et
pourquoi lui ne l'a pas moi de la N
libéré parce que je j'aime toujours je
cherche toujours des titres pour moi un
titre ça ça doit ça doit claquer c'est
c'est pas un résumé non plus et il y
avait à la fois euh libéré parce que
bien sûr libéré d'une charge puis
c'était un clin d'œil à Paris libéré et
au parisiens libérés j'ai même choisi la
vieille tipo du Parisien libéré dans le
pour pour pour pour faire mon le le le
générique début donc j'ai retrouver la
le le Parisien Libéré de de
44 à un moment dans l'entretien il vous
dit j'ai fait mon temps on est donc en
janvier 2013 vous venez de le dire
est-ce que ça vous a étonné d'entendre
ça oui ça m' plus d'un an avant de
partir ça m'a étonné parce que ça m'a
fait plaisir même ça me fait plaisir
comme réalisateur de l'entendre
c'est-à-dire que c'est c'est une des
choses
qui j'ai j'ai j'ai maintenant commencé à
filmer pas mal d'hommes et de femmes
politiques et c'est une des choses qui
m'a toujours marqué c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que j'avais filmé pendant 6 mois
George Frèche pour le grand écran c'est
de voir impossibilité de de de l'immense
majorité des hommes et femmes politiques
de raccrocher et et honnêtement des
hommes politiques qui vous disent j'ai
fait mon temps alors faudrait demander à
à Michel cotta à Renaud d'Elli mais je
pense qu'il il y en a pas tant que ça
c'està dire que est-ce que est-ce que
vous entendrez un
jour le maire de Lyon Gérard
Colom dire j'ai fait mon temps
Jean-Claude Godin la bonne preuve
JeanClaude Godin c'est un autre George
frche d'une certaine façon de mourir sur
scène enfin peu importe l'âge qu'il aura
c'està dire c'est c'est c'est une espèce
de l'homme politique il est très souvent
dans une solitude absolu donc il n'y a
plus que ça donc c'està dire de dire je
ne me représente pas c'est comme un
sportif c'està dire qu'il est obligé d'y
retourner c'est dire qu'un homme
politique c'est c'est comme après après
une Coupe du Monde de foot ou après les
Jeux Olympiques on pense à et dans 4 ans
on repart quoi vous vous êtes d'accord
avec cette analyse là ça vous a étonné
d'entendre comme ça Bertrand de la Noé
plus d'un an avant
de quitter ses fonctions dire j'ai fait
mon temps c'est fini non c'est étonnant
effectivement pour un homme politique
mais autant qu'on les uns et les autres
on connaissait de la Noé de lui ça ne
m'étonne pas parce que c'est un peu une
règle de vie lorsque il est passé dans
les à la pub il a mis fin à sa carrière
politique brutalement il a repris après
c'est c'est quel manquun à mon avis a de
multiples facettes et qui est cout
du fait de laisser tomber pour rebondir
et il y a une fois où il a quand même
laissé tomber volontairement c'est donc
2008 et la candidature au primaire
socialiste où effectivement il a surpris
aussi tout le monde dans lâchant
brusquement pied parce que d'un seul
coup ça ne l'intéressait plus c'était
pas cette bagarre qu'il voulait avoir
c'était autre chose qu'il voulait dire
m' et puis le deuxième exemple quand
même qu'on peut citer c'est dans cette
maison surtout celui de Jean-Pierre Bell
qui a donc dit le président du Sénat qui
a donc dit effectivement on a salué ça
les uns et les autres comme une une vie
originalité qui a dit qu'il ne serait
plus candidat à la présidence du Sénat
mais c'est ultra rare je sais pas si
Rena en conna d' pour moi c'est
tellement rare d'ailleurs que je me
souviens lors de sa réélection lorsqu'il
avait annoncé en qu' ne ferait pas plus
de mandat et qui ne se prentait pas pas
tout à fait franc moi je ne le croyais
pas c'est que pour fréquenter
effectivement les politique de longue
date d'abord j'ai appris parfois à
douter un peu de leur de leurs paroles
et puis c'est vrai qu'après tout ils
peuvent changer d'engagement c'est
c'est légitime et franchement je je ne
le croyais pas au départ je pensais
qu'il allait revenir au fur à mesure de
son mandat d'utant qu'il avait compris
des interrogations sur sur la succession
sur le personnage adinalgo donc qui vu
la stature le poids qui avait acquis de
la Noé donc ce fait de raccroché au bout
simplement de deux mandat que ce soit
par rapport au grand baron qui é voquait
violent un peu dans toutes les régions
du pays quel que soient les étiquettes
c'est un phénomène rarissime je pense
qu'il y a toujours un peu les deux
facettes chez de laané c'estàd que ça
illustre donc un côté atypique qu'on
évoquait une forme d'honnêteté
d'honnêteté intellectuelle pour le
coup mais aussi d'orgueil c'est un
personnage qui quand même extrêmement
orgueil il faut pas c'est-à-dire aussi
non c'estd queussi à partir du moment où
il l'a dit est tellement dit et répété
que ce serait se trahir lui-même que de
revenir sur cet
engagement Michel cota évoquait le le le
le congrès de reins de de 2008 s'il va
pas jusqu'au bout aussiil y a aussi une
forme d'orgueil c'est-à-dire qu'il n'a
pas eu le score c'est très bien raconté
dans le film auquel il s'attendait que
tout le monde lui avait annoncé à
commencé par François Holland d'ailleurs
et comme il est en dessous de la barre
il aurait pu encore l'emporter lors de
l'élection du premier secrétaire et il
décide de se retirer et de ne pas aller
jusqu'au bout donc il y a toujours les
deux facettes cette liberté cette
honnêteté cette authenticité du
personnage qui en même temps s'appuie
sur un orgueil assez olympique il faut
bien le dire Bernard ou je crois qu'il y
a aussi c'est un personnage un peu
atypique dans le monde politique que
vous demander il n'a pas que la
politique il est pas il a pas toujours
envie d'avoir envie si vous voulez la
règle dans la politique c'est un moteur
une ambition à tout crain et il dit même
à un moment pardon de vous couper il il
dit je n'ai pas besoin du pouvoir pour
respirer c'est ça he et alors j'ira même
j' presque le contraire et il a besoin
de respirer donc peut-être un peu moins
de pouvoir même si son ambition était
très très importante et compris
peut-être les plus hautes destinées de
l'État pourquoi pas il y a un moment où
il y a une certaine lassitude chez lui
et il fera pas le combat à tout prix il
fera pas le combat à tout prix et et il
a envie de faire autre chose dans la vie
Jupé à ce côté tentation de Venise lui
il a peut-être la tentation de Bizerte
ou la tentation d'autres pays ou
d'autres endroits où il existe en dehors
de la vie politique je suis même un peu
pr persuadé bien que n'ayant pas eu de
confidence de lui que le premier mandat
c'était déjà bien et qu' une certaine
lcitude au fond ce qui était important
c'était de gagner il ne croyait pas à
cette victoire là en 2001 il fait le
combat et il il le croit petit à petit
peut-êre peut-être pas possible et puis
il gagne alors évidemment c'est une
c'est une divine surprise quand même
quelque part jusqu'au bout il a dit on
va se faire battre jusqu'au bout
jusqu'au soir du premier tour il dit on
sera encore battu et puis il gagne alors
c'est formidable pour lui mais
l'essentiel est dit à partir de là
la le pouvoir au quotidien h
tout n'est pas très intéressant pour lui
dans une ville comme Paris comme dans
toutes les villes de France ou du monde
il faut s'occuper de plus petites choses
et des plus grandes choses et lui
s'intéresse pas forcément à tout il a
d'autres d'autres zones d'intérêt que le
pouvoir purement
municipalan est-ce que vous l'avez revu
depuis Bertrand de laané oui je l'ai
revu la semaine dernière comment va-t-il
il va bien et c'est une surprise pour
moi
autant c'était pas une surprise que qui
ne se représente pas c'estàd que l'ayant
vu longtemps je savais que cette part
d'orgueil justement était prédominante
et que la parole donnée c'est important
chez lui comme chez Jospin même si
honnêtement chez Jospin le fait que il
dise je je je quitte la vie politique et
qu'il essaye un peu pathétiquement
d'ailleurs de revenir en 2006 2007 ça
pour le coup je trouvais que ça ne lui
ressemblait pas pour reprendre une
expression jospinienne et et et et je
pense que que
j'ai fait les paris avec des copains
quand
ils en janvier 2013 mais évidemment
journalist par je suis pas journaliste
mais j'ai fait quand même des paris
peut-être avec des journalistes
justement et j'ai gagné contre les
journalist AZ regard oui oui bien sûr
mais et donc il me disait mais bien sûr
qu'il va être ministre quoi bien sûr que
tu vas voir après les municipales VO TR
ministre j'ai dit peut-être que je me
trompe mais je pense que non je pense
qu'il ne sera pas ministre justement
est-ce que quelqu'un autour de saette
table sait si Bertrand de la Noé a eu
des propositions pour des postes
ministéri est-ce qu'il les a refusé
est-ce qu'il les a ignoré je pense qu'il
en a eu en
2012 au moment de la constitution du
premier gouvernement héros mais je ne
jureraai pas qu'il en a eu cette fois-ci
après l'abandon mais peut-être que là
pour le coup vous êtes il on en a parlé
de la justice on en a parlé comme garde
des oui la justice on av parlé aussi à
la place de Christian tobir au début
2012 ce qui est vrai c'est que lors du
remanement du du de la fin du mois Mar
c'est du changement de de de de Premier
ministre euh François Hollande a évoqué
son nom devant certains de ses
collaborateurs à haute voie en même
temps pour repousser l'hypothèse mais
l'hypothèse d'olanoétinou a traversé
l'esprit du président de la République
même si c'était immédiatement pour
énumérer les difficultés qui faisaient
aux yeux de Hollande que ça n'était pas
possible de nommer de la mais en tout
cas il était quand même dans dans dans
son esprit il était dans la minette mais
pas pas au point d'en sortir et sinon je
pense quand même pour Bernard bled
disait que d'abord je pense que de l'
pensait qu'il allait gagner en 2001 même
s'il disait
que de enfin il y croyait en tout cas il
y croyait vraiment en 95 quand il mène
les les les listes Paris s'éveill il n'y
croit pas enfin il sait que l'ambition
c'est de gagner des arrondissements en
2001 l'ambition c'est clairement de
gagner Paris ensuite c'est quand même un
homme très politique c'està dire que
quand vous me demandez comment va-t-il
je trouve qu'il va bien mais moi j'ai
toujours une inquiétude bon après
municipal c'était hier quand même donc
pourrait y avoir le BLZ class je pense
que ça peut arriver parce que même si
lui est arrivé de faire d'autres choses
dans la vie et notamment Michel cota l'a
rappelé tout à l'heure après en 86 8 il
est quand même resté toujours Bernard
bled me démentira pas conscier de Paris
donc il a pas totalement raccroché avec
la politique à un moment donné il était
plus très peu de temps alors mais mais
c'était pas c'était pas sa il a voulu
garder en tout cas toujours qui s'est
présenté à Avignon qu' a pas pu se
présenter mais c'était quand même suite
àche dire que c'est une décision qu'il a
prise qu'il a essayé de de positiver
mais au fond euh quand même s'il avait
été si le parachutage s'était bien passé
à viignon alors aujourd'hui il est ravi
il dit c'est très bien ce qui m'est
arrivé ce crche dans le vlus philosof
mais euh au fond euh c'est quand même un
homme qui a fait beaucoup carrière en
politique dans le parti qui a été à un
moment un apparat chic et effectivement
qu' a d'autres envies mais je je pense
que le rythme de sa vie notamment de
depuis 20020 et depuis qu'il est qu'il
était et lu maire de Paris ce rythme là
je pense qu'il va falloir qu'il qu'il
réinvente la vie hein Michel cot je
revois son élection hein de 2001 et donc
on se rappelle la rivalité avec Jacques
Lang et quand même un des atouts de
Jacques Lang était de dire ma notoriété
est 1000 fois il a un déficit comme on
dit de la Noé un déficit de notoriété et
moi j'ai quand même entendu à ce
moment-là peut-être que de la Noé pensa
qu'il a allait qui allait perdre mais
dire euh euh si euh si ce que je si je
comprends bien la politique il faut pas
seulement la notoriété il faut aussi
aller sur place partout approcher les
gens approcher leurs problèmes et c'est
ce qu'il a fait il a fait une campagne
absolument exemplaire euh voilà alors il
aurait très bien pu ne pas être élu mais
ça prouve quand même et ça je crois que
ça a été pour lui un bonheur intense
après tellement de pilonnages venant
d'en haut quand même disant qu'il
vraiment il avait pas la fibre euh et
qui serait pas élu et ben je crois que
ça lui a fait un très grand plaisir oui
parce que je pense qu'il a été très
longtemps sous-estimé ça indéiablement
il été sous-estimé ycpris d'abord dans
son propre camp aussi d'ailleurs par ses
adversaires politiques et c'est vrai que
ça venait ce succès il est venu après
toute une période euh où il était un
conseiller de Paris dans l'ombre et où
il était à peu près tout seul euh dans
sa soupente avec Laurent Farry son
conseiller le plus proche qu'on voit
aussi dans le film et cetera et à un
moment où le groupe socialiste
n'existait pas la Gauche à Paris
n'existait pas aujourd'hui on a
l'impression que c'est devenu un bastion
du Parti socialiste Paris sur surtout vu
de l'état du PS dans le reste du pays il
faut quand même voir d'où il vient et
qu'effectivement déjà la victoire dans 6
arrondissement 95 c'était un triomphe et
et que c'est il a connu lui les années
de vache maigre de la Gauche à Paris et
les deux grands chlem successifs de de
Jac et il a tellement bien transformé
les choses que à un moment donné il
était présidentiable et je voudrais
qu'on réécoute sa version des
faits d'abord il y a une coalition de
Dominique
stroscon personnellement Martine au
Laurent Fabius Henri Emmanuel Benoît
amamont pour me barrer la route et je
peux même vous dire qu'il y avait déjà
l'esquise d'un accord avec segelen Royal
parce que il ne fallait pas que je sois
premier secrétaire car toutes ces
personnes aux intérêts relativement
divergents pensaient que si je devenais
premier secrétaire je
prenais de l'avance sur une éventuelle
candidature à la présidence de la
République c'est le premier fait qui est
prouvé ce qui est vrai c'est que si
j'avais été un peu plus ficel peut-être
que j'aurais gagné peut-être que
j'aurais été le candidat à la
présidentielle peut-être même que
j'aurais été élu et alors et on
accueille un historien sur notre plateau
Bruno F bonsoir alors ce et alors il est
très étonnant et alors qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire dans la bouche de berand de la
Noé si j'avais été un peu plus
ficelle je pense aussi une forme
d'orgueil de sa part c'est que il
considère qu'effectivement il s'est
heuré à une coalition d'ppinchic et que
lui n'a pas voulu recourir au même
procédés que ceux dont il a été victime
c'est l'idée moi je fais de la politique
autrement je fais de la politique
différemment c'est en partie vrai c'est
vrai mais je pense que c'est aussi
encore une fois lié à ce personnage un
peu atypique qui malgré la déception du
score qu'il obtient au congrès de de
reimce bah il est encore en position
d'être candidat et peut-être même d'être
élu mais c'est vrai qu'en face il a il a
raison là-dessus il a raison la plupart
des ténors du PS à l'époque se mettent
d'accord pour ne pas lu lui confier le
parti parce que il faut s'en souvenir en
2008 c'est lui qui est très nettement en
tête dans les sondages des présidentiels
potentiels socialistes le le le le
l'envolet de Dom schoscan sa mort sa
peine hein mais c'est en 200920 que
schoscan va devenir le le le le le le
Messi espéré de la gauche à l'époque
mais de la Noé à ce moment-là est
vraiment sorti dur rant et c'est pour ça
qu'effectivement les autres ne veulent
pas le laisser prendre partie moi je me
rappelle très bien son discours de de
2008 son discours d'abandon euh de de la
compétition donc au premier secrétariat
euh qui devait l'amener à la présidence
mais euh son discours a été vraiment
formidable moi je me rappelle maîreed
pendant tout le temps c'est vraiment un
orateur extraordinaire dont je n'avais
pas tellement conscience avant avant et
puis je voyais derrière lui ces troupes
en larme pratiquement et euh et puis
quand on a quand on quand le discours
s'est arrêté je rappelle avoir vu des
gens des proches y compris François
Hollande disant mais enfin il aurait pu
passer encore en réalité il a été euh
euh il a été énervé même bouleversé
bouleversé par cette euh tout le monde
avait dit à Martin aub de se retirer
elle ne le faisait pas il a été
bouleversé par cette euh candidature et
par la personne même et et j'ai
l'impression que quelque part il se
disait mais comment est-ce que je pu
susciter tellement d'hostilité moi qui
suis voilà et je crois que ça c'est très
important aussi pour lui il y a une part
d'orgueil il y a une part de volonté
d'être reconnu ce terme de ficelle là
qu'évoque bertandé pour le coup Holland
lui dans la même situation aurait été
plus ficul évidemment on le connait
Holland il a fait d'ailleurs la
politique comme ça la tête du P pendant
des années donc c'est vrai que c'est
vrai mais françoisolland ne comprenait
pas l'attitude de la Noé AR et lui-même
était é était surpris de cet abandon je
CIS qu'il a un mot excusez-moi qu'il
faut pour bien comprendre de la Noé il y
a une forme
d'affectivité chez le personnage et a
quelqu'un toute sa vie quand on la
regarde est une vie compliquée difficile
où il a des problèmes affvectifs
et et il ne non non non mais ça va pas
beaucoup avec la politique la politique
quand on dit ficelle on dit bon
finalement on tripatouille un peu et
puis ça marche VO lui il aime il aime
qu'on l'aime et c'est difficile pour lui
quand il voit que en situation peut-être
de gagner il est il est renvoyé dans ses
buts de manière un peu pas clair tois
pas pas pas extraordinairement clair et
alors il ira pas jusqu'au bout de ça il
y a des choses qui ne fera pas parce que
il a envie que ce soit spontané au fond
il a envie que on le on le hisse sur le
Pavoir et ça se fait pas comme ça ouais
alors alors ce qui ce qui est étonnant
dans le parcours de Bertrand Olano c'est
qu' résume assez bien l'histoire de la
fonction du maire de Paris c'est-à-dire
il est arrivé quasi inconnu ça l'a
positionné comme un éventuel candidat à
la présidence comme l'a dit François
Hollande l'histoire de France est marqué
par cette opposition état Paris le
préveau face au roi la ville face à la
cour la commune face à versaill
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui l'exécutif se
méfie toujours autant du maire de Paris
peut-être moins mais c'est vrai que si
on raisonne sur le long terme les
grandes dates de l'histoire de Paris
sont aussi des grandes dates de
l'histoire nationale et pendant très
longtemps on n' pas voulu qu'il y ait un
maire de Paris pourquoi parce que quand
il y a eu des maires de Paris ça a
toujours été des périodes
révolutionnaires alors on peut remonter
à Étienne Marcel 1357 mais plus proche
de nous si j'ose dire la Révolution
française tout le monde sait que les
Parisiens prennent la Bastille le 14
juillet 1789 mais avec quoi prennent-ils
la Bastille avec des armes qui sont
allés quérir à l'Hôtel de Ville le 13 la
veille et toute l'histoire de Paris
c'est ça le premier maire de Paris
l'astronome jean-slvain bi qui sera
aussi le premier président de
l'Assemblée nationale en 1789 et il
finira guillotiner et robes piierre
quand les choses commencent à tourner
mal pour lui à la Convention
c'est-à-dire au parlement national et
bien où va-t-il se réfugier à l'hôtel de
ville parce que là il y a une Commune
insurrectionnelle Paris c'est la grande
marmite Paris va avoir de nouveau un
maire en 1848 Paris va avoir de nouveau
un maire en
187071 et après la commune c'est terminé
il faudra attendre plus d'un siècle
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait quand se termine
le mandat de maire d'un certain Jules
Ferry et bien il y a une éclipse du
maire de Paris et le suivant ça sera
Jacques Chirac il y a pas de maire de
Paris de Jul ferry à Jacques Chirac par
contre il y a quand même un président du
conseil municipal mais qui a beaucoup
moins de pouvoir et alors effectivement
l'émancipation à Paris a été longue et
complexe vous venez de le dire c'est en
74 en fait que Valérie giscardesttin
engage une réflexion sur le le nouveau
statut de Paris pourquoi à ce moment-là
pourquoi Valérie giscardestin qu'est-ce
qu'il y a derrière cette volonté là
d'abord moi j'ai vécu un peu ça aussi en
direct je peux vous dire que il y a un
homme qui a beaucoup poussé giscar à le
faire il s'appelle Jacques Dominati
enfit le vrai réalisateur de cette idée
c'est Dominati qui a poussé Giscard à
lui dire Paris ne peut pas être la
dernière commune de France qui n'est pas
pas un maire élu ça n'a pas de sens
évidemment il y avait une petite
arrière-pensée c'est que Dominati
pensait qu'il pourrait être ce premier
maire
là l'histoire a fait que c'est pas du
tout comme ça que ça s fait et que
l'épisode de dornano n'a pas été
brillant et puis c'est comme ça que
Chirac arrive derrière mais l'idée c'est
quand même de faire de de Paris enfin
une ville qui n'est plus sous tutelle de
l'État et à qui on pardonne la commune
et toutes les
révolutions je me rappelle d'une
certaine façon puisquon cite Valérie j
gardestin ça a été quand même une
déconvenue terrible pour lui parce qu'au
fond ramener le maire de de Paris et et
je trouve qu'effectivement c'était de
c'était ce qu'il fallait faire mais en
se disant je vais quand même mettre un
des miens et ce sera quand même un socle
et se faire passer sous le nez par une
campagne éblouissante de jacesirac parce
que c'est vraiment une campagne
éblouissante qu'il avait c'était une des
rigolades je me rappelle les plus
important
1977 que c'est pour ça qu' y avait
arrièrepensé de jaces Bernard instant
mais il y avait aussi des
arrrièrepensais de Val carardesttin
lui-même puisqueà l'époque il est
président de la République mais il a une
bonne partie de son camp en tout cas
contre lui c'est qu'il est le président
il a été élu quasiment sans parti alors
que les golistes enfin même si Jacques
Chirac s'est rallié à lui avec une
partie des des députés golistes mais en
tout cas sont très vite en opposition
donc créer un maire de Paris c'est
évidemment essayer d'en faire un bastion
giskardien de donner ça soit à JAC
Dominati soit ensuite il y a eu
l'épisode de la candidature de de Michel
dorano mais il y avait aussi cette
volonté là du président de la République
de se constituer sa majorité à lui ça
passit aussi par is alors justement
c'est comme ça qu'il y a eu une sorte
aussi c'est de de révolution en quelque
sorte puisque ce qui était prévu ne ne
s'est pas passé et et il y a aussi eu
des un siècle plus tard un siècle plus
tard une émancipation de Paris par
rapport au pouvoir central qui était un
héritier de la commune en fait
voilà est-ce que quandoup est-ce que
quand Jack shirac démissionne de ses
fonctions de Premier ministre en 76
est-ce que Valéri carardestin a une idée
de ce que veut faire JAC Chirac est-ce
que Jacques shirac lui-même Bernard bled
sait déjà que la maie de Paris est en
ligne de mire non non très honnêtement
non le coup bah c'estd que je suis sûr
autant autant que j'ai pu vivre cette
période là je pense que d'autres
réfléchissent pour lui il y en a au
moins trois marie-fance garot pierre
juillet et et pasquis qui se disent à
partir du moment où tu sors de de
Matignon comme ils avaient chacun une
idée sur l'avenir n il ser d'ailleurs
pas Tromp peut-être un peu dans le
timing mais enfin au bout du compte ils
ont eu raison il faut trouver quelque
chose le hasard voulu par giscar leur
offre une occasion
exceptionnelle F mon billet comme je dis
comme on dit aujourd'hui que Chirac lui
il était en corz sa terre corisienne il
était député de corz il était très bien
là-bas et quand on lui parle de Paris il
dit qu c'est que ça euh
qu'est-ceon il y a une anecdote qui est
connue lors de la démission de Chirac
justementement à matigon savtin le
raconté à plusieurs reprises lors de
leur entretien de leur tête à tête quand
Jack chir est venu présenter sa
démission àusquestin euh gisc raconte
que Chirac lui a dit qu'il allait
quitter la politique et ouvrir une
galerie de peinture mais giscar ajoute
aussitôt qu'il na évidemment pas cru
voilà il pensait évidemment que Chirac
n'allait pas faire ça alors entre
tempemps il y a eu une loi la loi du 31
décembre
1975 qui va donner une autre dimension à
la fonction de maire de Paris ren oui
c'està-dire que encore une fois on part
d'un d'un État où il y a un conseil
municipal qui devient c'est important en
à la fin de l'année 1967 Conseil de
Paris ça a l'air de rien mais il faut
penser aussi à une réforme qui a rendu
tout cela inévitable c'est la réforme
départementale de 67 c'est-à-dire
qu'avant Paris c'était la grosse commune
du département de la Scine mais il y
avait d'autres communes dans le
département de la scinene à la fin 67
Paris c'est une commune mais c'est aussi
un département et d'ailleurs le Conseil
de Paris devient en même temps conseil
général sont les mêmes élus qui qui sont
conseillers municipaux et conseillers
généraux donc déjà ça donne une
dimension particulière à Paris et puis
un maire va vraiment émerger il faut
savoir que entérieurement le président
du conseil municipal il était réélu
d'année en année alors certains ont pu
être élu plusieurs fois mais enfin il y
avait même pas la durée non seulement
les pouvoirs étaient plus restreints
mais il y avait pas la durée et puis le
maire de Paris ou son prédécesseur ont
face à lui un personnage qu'on oublie
toujours mais qui a un pouvoir très
important sur le territoire de la
capitale c'est le préfet de police qui
lui n'est pas un élu mais un haut
fonctionnaire et la préfecture de police
comment dirais-je administre un certain
nombre de domaines qui dans n'importe
quelle autre commune serait municipal
donc il le maire de Paris c'est une
renaissance et c'est quelqu'un qui va
devoir conquérir un pouvoir qui lui
avait échappé pendant pendant très
longtemps est-ce que c'est à ce
moment-là que la mairie de Paris devient
un trempelin pour l'Élysée c'est
clairement à ce moment-là que ça devient
un trempelin disons que faut voir
précédemment dans l'histoire vous avez
eu des personnages qui ont eu des
carrières nationales après après avoir
été soit maire soit président du conseil
municipal j'ai cité Jules Ferri on
pourrait parler de clémenceo c'est
complètement oublié mais clémenceo
pendant un an a présidé le conseil
municipal de Paris il était jeune voilà
ensuite il va faire sa carrière dans le
Var et longtemps plus tard il sera
président du Conseil deux fois
c'est-à-dire chef du gouvernement chef
de l'État non mais chef du gouvernement
bon et puis à l'inverse il y a plein de
personnages complètement oubliés sauf
des Parisiens parce qu'ils ont laissé
leur nom à un hôpital à une rue marmotan
ovelac castagnarie et quelques autres
complètement oublié aujourd'hui qui ont
eu un pouvoir à un moment mais sans
jamais imaginer même un ministère c'est
complètement complètement différent le
cas de Chirak c'est un cas de transition
puisque vous l'avez dit il est député de
la Corse il le reste en étant Maire de
Paris et il a le droit de le faire maire
de Paris c'est une fonction locale donc
on peut par ailleurs et oui et on peut
avoir les deux les deux on peut avoir
une fonction parlementaire nationale une
fonction locale pas forcément sur le
même territoire aujourd'hui ça passerait
sans doute très mal c'était déjà
critiqué dans les années 70 et encore
plus 80 mais ça pass pass encore
aujourd'hui c'est très difficile pour
quelqu'un qui a été élu ailleurs de
Paris de devenir élu parisien on peut
naître en dehors de Paris et faire une
belle carrière dans Paris mais avoir été
un élu non parisien et devenir parisien
c'est difficile et je pense que
l'inverse doit être encore plus
difficile de se présenter aujourd'hui
parce que la décentralisation est passée
par là aussi et qu'on a perdu cette idée
qui avait dominé le 18e 19e siècle que
Paris était une sorte de phare un lid de
Vict par exemple ouais est-ce que en
arrivant à l'hôtel de ville avec le
budget de plusieurs milliards de francs
que ça représente à l'époque3
33 ce qui est la plus que la plupart des
ministères la possibilité de recevoir
des chefs d'État étrangers de passage
est-ce que c'est ça qui a fait
comprendre à un moment donné à Jacques
Chirac que ça pouvait être là un
exercice tremplin moi je crois pas
beaucoup à ça parce que à peéiori on dit
ça en réalité l'histoire nous le
montre shirac c'est en fait le
contreexemple à chaque fois on dit quand
on n pas shirac est né à Paris dans le
5e mais il est pas étiqueté comme étant
parisien parce qu'il est élu de corise
donc le contreexemple c'est qu'il y a
bien quelqu'un qui vient de province qui
veut prendre Paris
depuis il y en a pas beaucoup d'exemples
à cel deuxè deuxième
contreexemple le fait qu'on soit
dépositaire du pouvoir municipal ça
donne un poids extraordinaire je crois
que c'est pas tellement ça le fait c'est
que un il y a il est le premier maire
élu ça c'est vrai ça c'est c'est une
grosse différence par rapport à ses
prédécesseurs
deuxièmement Paris est quand même la
capitale de la France dans un état qui
se veut décentralisé mais qui reste
extrêmement centralisé c'est le c'est le
siège de tout le de tous les pouvoirs
administratifs et de l'état donc
forcément celui qui est là a quelque
chose de plus est-ce que l'idée de dire
on a la possibilité depuis l'Ancien
Régime de recevoir des personnalités
étrangères notamment les chefs d'État à
Paris ça donne un petit plus
naturellement oui sur le plan
international mais ça reste
anecdotique peut avoir accès au monde en
étant à l'AM par la réalité Bernard je
suppose vous allez pas me démentir c'est
que depuis 76 depuis qu'il a quitté
matigon Jacques Chirac ne pense qu'à ça
alors c'est pas parce qu'il été ma il é
candidat c'est parce qu'il voulait être
candidat qu'il a été maire donc c'est et
c'est comme ça d'ailleurs que Charles
pascoy et mariefance G l'ont convaincu
que il fallait en tout cas se se replier
sur des positions solides en attendant
la prochaine élection le timing comme
vous dites n'a pas été respecté mais la
volonté de Ja shirac il aurait fait la
même chose en corz he si on se souvient
de son élection présidentielle d'abord
il a d'abord été candidat deux fois
alors qu'il était maire de Paris et ça
ne l'a pas servi même s'il avait cette
stature déjà qui émergit et lorsqu'il
est élu en 95 je pense que le principal
à tout c'était pas gagné il a quand même
été de justesse et on se souvient de
cette campagne là son principal Atou
c'était surtout de de détenir les clés
du RPR c'est surtout le fait qu'il était
président du RPR qu' l'a servi
finalement pour réussir à éliminer doard
bedure et on se souvient que il avait eu
du mal et qu'il c'était il était il
s'est traîné très longtemps dans la
campagne derrière le fait d'être maire
de Paris l'a servi aussi sans doute mais
c'était anecdotique par rapport au PO
que représentait le fait d'avoir le RPR
le parti ses moyens ses finances et ses
militants derrière lui donc donc c'est
pas tralement un tremplin
parce ça a marché pour JAC Chirac mais
c'était pas un tremin et ça n pas marché
pour une sorte de laboratoire parce que
quand même le quand quand quand Jacques
Chac est parti de la mairie il a emmené
avec lui beaucoup de ses collaborateurs
et même h de ses ministres pas beaucoup
non non il a pas emmené beaucoup de
collaborateurs ououi fait pas beaucoup
rappelle que Paris c'est 42000
fonctionnaires hein donc mais ce que je
veux dire c'est des collaborateurs
proches c'est des gens avec qui il a
travaillé avec qui il a formé une équipe
en général on naime pas arriver à des
postes aussi il a pas énormément emmené
de gens euh à
l'éisée d'ailleurs ça a été une une
question qui s'est posée à ce moment-là
pourquoi et cetera bon il a bien quand
il est parti de Paris il a fermé la
porte dehôtel de ville il a ouverte la
porte de l'Élysée terminé d'ailleurs la
suite a montré
que héritage oui mais il a fermé
longtemps la porte pour montrer que
cette porte n'était plus la sienne oui
trs attaché Paris puce qu'il a voulu
rester il a bien eu 3 mois nommé à la
Présidence il est resté uniquement pour
des raisons politiques c'est aussi pour
des raisons juridiques ENF judiciaire
quand j'ai dit fermer la porte j'ai dit
fermer la porte exactement ce qu'il y a
derrière la porte hein donc il a bien
fait la saisure entre les deux et comme
le disait Michel Toader évidemment tout
son bu a été ça l'hôtel de ville lui a
permis non pas de faire de laboratoire
je me souviens 88 la campagne de 88 que
j'ai eu l'honneur de de diriger sur le
plan
technique on avait un slogan le slogan
qui a fait qui a foiré complètement
c'est de dire ce qu'il a fait pour Paris
va le faire pour la France c'est une
catastrophe les gens ne voulaient pas du
tout ça les Parisiens disaient nous on
veut le garder que ils étaient alors on
a abandonné ce slogan ce qui veut ce qui
à contrario explique que au fond ça n'a
pas tellement servi ce point de vue là
le laboratoire ça n'a pas très bien
fonctionné alors c'est comme ça ça a
quand même bien fonctionné après de de
deux échecs non ce que les Français
préféraient effectivement la publicité
c'était au contraire le petit village
l'église utilisé par très bien compris
c'était pas ce qu'on voulait est-ce que
jacquesirac a donné a créé une une une
dimension à la mairie de de Paris ça
c'est oui ça c'est oui parce que c'était
sa dimension c'estd que il s'est mis à
la hauteur de Paris et Paris s'est mis à
la hauteur de Chirac en fait il y a eu
ça c'est vrai que Paris est devenu au
travers de sa personnalité quelque chose
de différent que ce que j'ai connu quand
je suis rentré en 62 évidemment l'époque
les préfets bon les conseillers de Paris
ne cons conseill ne conse ne comptait
pas beaucoup bon lui il a amené quelque
chose de plus d'abord ord parce qu'il a
un tempérament et quelqu'un qui qui qui
est
pushing utilisé tout ce qu' pouvait pour
avoir un rayonnement international c'est
vrai ça bien sûr que oui il a
ser à exister il a fait des grandes
choses à quoi ça sert pourquoi on court
après la des moyens quand même c'est des
moyens considérables des moyens pour
faire grande ville de France du
monde monde comme dirait monsieur blanc
V
monde par prestigieux où on a des moyens
pour faire des choses et si j'ose dire
c'est pas cert ça doit pas être facile
je suis pas de par mais c'est pas le
territoire le plus compliqué à gérer non
plus c'estd qu'on a on a des moyens pour
assumer les ambitions mais il y a aussi
source de richesse je il y a des zones
du territoire français qui sont beaucoup
plus compliquées me semble-t-il à gérer
à développer y compris enfin surtout
dans une période de crise durable telle
que cette cont on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui c'est devenu une espèce
de même de de de fiève de prospérité et
et de et de et de paix au regard de du
reste de l'agone pourquoi des des hommes
politiques comme François Fillon ou
Philippe Seguin euh se sont retirés
pourquoi ils sont pas allés jusqu'au
bout bah ce gar il est allé ce gar d'une
certaine façon il est allé jusqu'au bout
il a donné l'impression de se retirer
pendant la campagne c'est vrai tellement
il faisit pas à la fin mis quelqu'un son
arrondissement pour êre sûr d'être battu
ça vit bien qu'il y avait une
méconnaissance totale de Paris bon comme
le disait tout à l'heure notre ami quand
on vient à Paris d'ailleurs il faut
quand même un peu se renseigner avant
pour savoir comment ça fonction
il y a une élection à Paris c'est pas
une désignation si vou pas parce que
comm monsieur Balad pensait qu'il
fallait désigné en 95 il a pas été
désigné parce que l'élection l' a montré
qu'il a pas été élu quand sin est arrivé
il a pensé que bah c'était l'affaire
était ficelée tout le monde lui disait
de l'Élysée à matigon passant par le RPR
il faut y aller tu es élu élu c'est pas
comme ça que ça se passe Fillon c'est
autre chose Fillon il est pas allé
borlot n est pas allé non plus c'est
pour les mêmes raisons parce que là il y
a un vrai risque de se faire con en fait
c'est devenu trop risqué oui il y a un
risque de faire quand même
il y a quand même un héritage
aujourd'hui maintenant ça fait une
quinzaine d'années qu' et on l'a vu y
compris la candidate Nathalie cossisco
Moriset ça n'est pas la seule c'est
peut-être pas la principale raison de sa
défaite mais je pense que l'atmosphère
de sérénité et d'harmonie toute relative
qui règne encore dans la droite
parisienne l'a pas vraiment servi
pourant la campagne on a bien vu que
tout son camp n'était pas en ordre de
marche parce qu'il y a toujours des PL
qui se sont pas refermés depuis le
départ de Jacques Chirac au sein de
l'endroite parisienne et tout n'est pas
guéri tout n'est pas côérisé donc il y a
encore des des coups à prendre quand on
est candidat à la droite en tout cas à
la mérie de Paris oui puis effectivement
l'image de de Jacques Chirac donc qui a
dominé cette cette mairie pendant son
temps al bien sûr il y a eu jeantibé
après mais justement l'interrogation
était d'autant plus lourde pour de laané
parce qu'au fond est est-ce que de laané
a la stature est-ce qu'il pourra est-ce
qu'il pourra et il est arrivé il est
arrivé c'est un MRE qui existe pas dans
le genre flamboyant de chiracou est-ce
est-ce que un maire le maire de Paris
a-t-il le pouvoir de fa sononner
l'électorat à son image on a dit que
Jacques Chirac avait un peu
enembourgeoisé Paris que les classes
populaires étaient parties en banlieu
puis après on a dit que Bertrand de
laané il a fait venir plus de Bobo les
jeunes cadres souciux des questions
écolos et cetera est-ce que est-ce que
le maire a un impact réel sur l'image
sur la population de sa ville c'est la
façon dont il gère son affaire ce qui
fait souvent la sociologie c'est surtout
l'urbanisme surtout la manière pr loyers
voilà c'est bon ch qu'il a fait il a
fait le le grand le grand plan de
rénovation de l'Est parisien fourbie
énorme un truc qui a pris 60 % des du
budget d'investissement pendant 6 ans
résultat des courses sur les six
arrondissements qu'on a complètement
refait on a perdu 5 pour montrer que
finalement tout tout tout tout public
est ne vous rend pas nécessairement ce
que vous lui AZ donner mais il
s'occupait pas de ça il fallait rénové
donc on a rénové rénové ça veut dire
qu'on a fait partir les petits gens des
gens qui qui avaient des LO voy où on
payait pas beaucoup d'argent mais qu'on
a cassé pour faire des des logements
neufs ces gens-là sont partis et puis
les artisans les petits artisans qui
faisaient aussi l'âme de Paris tout ça
ça a disparu alors est-ce qu'on peut
dire que c'est le maire qui l'a fait de
manière intelligente politique en se
disant je vais changer la sociologie par
rapport ce que je pense que pas je pense
qu'il avait envie de moderniser Paris et
et de la même façon de la Noé qui lui
était peut-être plus fin dans la
politique locale je en quelque sorte
hein il voyait faisit plus de la micro
politique que Chirac qui faisait plus de
la
macrooltique c'était de dire faut
peut-être quand même rendre à Paris une
certaine arme et les bobo c'est un peu
ça oui je pense que c'est aussi
largement l'évolution de la sociologie
de Paris qui produit son maire
c'est-à-dire qu'on a vu aussi Paris a
profondément changé entre ce qui était
que c'était sous les années chi que
c'est ce que la ville est devenue sous
les années de la Noé et je pense que
l'un des talents de la Noé ça a été de
comprendre et de coller aux
préoccupations sociétales d'une bonne
partieors ce qu'on appelle les bobos au
sens là même de par son personnage lui-
même et s rappelé dans le film d' jolent
c'est vrai que il fait son coming out en
98 il confesse publiquement son
homosexualité et cetera ce qui est un
quelque chose d'inédit dans la vie
politique française et il s'avère que ça
correspond avec une une spécificité
parisienne sur les questions sociétales
peut-être on regarde certaines autres
parties du territoire soit sur les
questions sociétales soit sur les
questions environnementales aussi et lui
il a joué très clairement de ces deux
tableaux sur ces deux tableaux là et à
l'inverse c'est vrai que Paris n'est pas
vraiment une ville prolétarienne c'est
pas l'électorat populaire qui est l à
gauche à Paris une dernière question le
temps va nous manquer Bren fini Paris
c'est une ville de droite de gauche
est-ce qu'il y a une couleur politique à
c'est ça qui est extraordinaire à Paris
sur le long terme c'est la plasticité de
cette ville et ça rejoint ce qui vient
d'être dit la population change d'abord
ce sont pas forcément les mêmes gens il
y a beaucoup de provinciaux qui viennent
qui repartent et puis la couleur évolue
Paris ville révolutionnaire ville rouge
au 19e siècle après l'affaire defus vote
largement nationaliste donc une forme de
droite populatière mais extrême
ouvertement antisémite dans certains
arrondissements et puis après la guerre
on a des scores communistes très élevés
y compris dans des arrondissements
parisiens qui aujourd'hui sont
ultrabourgeois donc il y a une grande
plasticité du vote à Paris et puis
également B des mouvements de population
tout à fait importants cela cumulé avec
le cloisonnement par arrondissement qui
a des effets ça donne des élections qui
sont très difficiles à anticiper Paris a
horreur de voter comme les journaux
disent que Paris va voter donc paril
nous réserve encore de belles surprises
merci à tous d'être venu sur ce plateau
j'aurais le plaisir de vous retrouver
dans 15 jours pour un débat sur les
femmes au Yémen à très vite sur public
sénna